three words that may be relevant to
julian edelman
five years from now hall of fame and
this question first came up after super
bowl 53 when he was named
the mvp frankly kind of by
default because the patriots only scored
13
points you can't give it to tom brady
one of the reasons why so few receivers
are mvps of the super bowl is because it
usually goes to the guy who threw the
passes
not the guy who catches the passes
unless there's some dominant statistical
performance
but i was sitting next to serene
williams who had one of the votes there
were maybe 15 votes for the super bowl
mvp
and she was like oh i don't know who to
vote for in this game
there was no there was no dominant
offensive performance edelman had a
solid game edelman deserved it for that
game but then all of a sudden we start
talking about not we but people start
talking about edelman
as a hall of famer hey great postseason
achievements by julian edelman second
only to
jerry rice when it comes to catches and
also i believe yards
in the postseason but in the regular
season
are you kidding me are you kidding me
his numbers aren't good enough i mean
his numbers are not good enough
to get to the hall of fame it's a silly
question like it really is
i don't know what i i i'm sorry but
that that part of it like julian edelman
awesome football player legend a part of
some of the biggest
moments in the history of the league
definitely
i mean rose to the occasion and huge
moments whether it's that falcons play
that we watched there before when the
ball was juggling around catching that
that play to the to win the game
basically against the seahawks here's
the foul
you know the falcons play how about the
the third and long down the middle where
he basically gets concussed against the
seattle seahawks
and spins off a big hit and should have
been taken out of the game and wasn't
but kept going and that's just the
player he is like hey
all of that is awesome hall of fame stop
it like
where did that even come from yeah i
mean patriots fans i know he's a legend
but he does just because he's a legend
for you guys does not mean hall of fame
i mean stop there were some in the media
they got there were some of the media
that got caught up in it yeah without
doing the research
620 catches 6822 yards
heinz ward has a thousand catches and
over 12 000 yards
and he's had a hard time migrating
through the funnel to get in and he's
and he's a super bowl mvp too
right he's a super bowl mvp too the
farthest he's gotten his semifinalist he
hasn't even gotten to the final 15.
so unless and until there is a bust in
the hall of fame
that looks just like heinz ward we can't
even have the conversation about julian
edelman
because in many respects i can't even
say they're the same guy because
ward had a much more prolific almost
twice the yards
career in the regular season than julian
edelman and and i don't want to hear the
excuses while he was stuck behind wes
welker well hey that's one of the
chapters in the hall of famer's career
if you're good enough get your ass on
the field instead of wes welker you
weren't good enough to beat out wes
welker
that's part of the chapter in your hall
of fame book yeah his stat i mean wes
welker would be the first guy you'd go
well he's got to get in the hall of fame
first and then we'll talk about julian
edelman
and then of course we don't think that's
going to happen hey to put it in
perspective
it's 156 all time with
receiving stats receiving yards it's
behind odell beckham jr
and in career yards odell beckham jr
hasn't played football in three years
he's still beating julian edelman
jarvis landry is almost a thousand yards
you know it's
it's it's insanity talk it was total
new england fan gushing and i understand
it because he's been a part of so many
big moments
but come on hall of fame that that's
definitely not not happening i mean
no patriots ring of honor you know
legend whatever you want to say
not a hall of famer here's the reality
though we have to think back to the 70s
and when the steelers won
four super bowls that decade it unlocked
the keys to canton
for a lot of guys including lynn swann
who based upon his regular season stats
had no business getting into canton and
i know the standards were different then
he still had ridiculously low numbers of
catches
and yards in the regular season but what
did he give us he gave us
super bowl 10 still to this day
one of the great single game
performances in nfl history with catches
that
we never had seen before whether it's
the the catch where he's falling down
which is an iconic moment in nfl history
the underrated
sideline acrobatic act where he somehow
is levitating
out of bounds and gets his feet back in
uh and i think that in some respects and
i've never heard this
i was 10 years old at the time this all
went down but i think when
the powers that be saw what lin swan did
in that game that may have planted the
seeds to
you know find a way to tweak the rules
to get more passing
into the game it's held a lot more fun
to watch that than it is to watch a guy
run the football
between the guard and the tackle so swan
got in
but i just don't think it's enough with
all the proliferation
of passing statistics and receivers who
are worthy
i don't think edelman gets in and you
throw on the ped asterisk
and i think that that that's enough to
keep him out well i i'd be
i'd be stunned if he gets in well
definitely i mean i i would be stunned
too
and i mean you you know you could say
what you want like you know yeah
it's it's impossible to even compare
that era to right now
it's it's it's not it's a backlog of
receivers
i mean we just mentioned we got
receivers jarvis landry is
he's in the middle of his career he's
got seven thousand yards receiving
it it blows julian edelman out of the
water he's still got years and years
left on his career that way
you know lynn swann said what you want
yeah the stats weren't the same they
weren't the same for the quarterbacks
either
nothing was the same terry bradshaw was
what right
north of 30 000 passing yards he might
have been less than that
you know it's hall of famer it's just
not even it's a different world
altogether
it's the effect on the game you know
julian edelman was really good
you knew you had to know where he is at
all times but it wasn't
like you were like oh it's because
julian edelman is gonna
beat our best corner man to man you know
all game long and do that
no it was more like hey we gotta stop
julian edelman because yeah he's good at
what he does
but man the niche in which the patriots
have created for him
he's a huge part of their offense it was
more offense related
it was about like hey we got to stop
this guy who has this role for the
patriots
whether it's amendola chris hogan or
or uh wes welker all thrived in that
position there
because it's geniusly uh concocted
with their play calling and their play
and their play design
through belichick and mcdaniels so he
was a benefit factor of that
lin swann was a guy at least where you
were like
well i don't know we just we gotta cover
him we gotta watch out he can run by all
our guys
and he can jump over all our guys and he
could catch a slant and run by all our
guys
and we're gonna have to do something
about him because they don't do anything
offensively they just tell him to run
straight
or run straight and make a left or run
straight and make a right that's all he
does and we just have to stop him
because he's a great talent
to me there's great difference in that
you know amendola i mean
edelman really good but more a lot of
the success is because of the offense
and the situation he was put in and the
role that was created there
in new england and invented by them that
he really took advantage of and ran with
and killed it with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports